male northern elephant seals know who
their rivals are on the beach you don't
even have to see the other guy they
remember his voice and the rhythm in his
call humans do the same thing when we
listen to other people's voices that's
how we can put a name to a voice even
without seeing someone for elephant
seals learning and remembering other
males calls the matter of survival every
winter the male's gather at rook waves
from Northern California to Baja Mexico
site and meet the sights for females
raising their front flippers and
rhythmically roaring by playing back
natural and modified calls to a seal
colony I just show that the male's
did remember each other's voices when
subordinate males heard an alphas call
that was sped up or slowed down they
stayed put but they fled the call was
similar to the alphas normal one
subordinate males are usually smaller
than the alphas and they move away when
they hear Adama call males that don't
move away our attacked alphas violently
lunge at competitor sometimes causing
serious even lethal injury so it makes
sense for the male elephant seal to
memorize their rivals or is it they need
to use those down to decide on the best
strategy 3 or fight
you